IS FAKE NEWS AND THE
PRESIDENT DENIES THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FORMER
PLAYMATE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BLAMING
DEMOCRATS FOR THE FAILURE SO
FAR OF EFFORTS TO COME UP
WITH IMMIGRATION LEGISLATION
THAT ADDRESSES THE FATE OF
THE SO-CALLED DREAMERS.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
TELLS US WHERE THINGS STAND
RIGHT NOW.
HELLO, PETER.
>> HI, MIKE, NOW IT IS THE
HOUSE'S TURN TO TACKLE
IMMIGRATION.
THE MOST BUZZ IS LINKED TO
YOU A PACKAGE AUTHORED BY
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN BOB
GOODLATTE WHICH ADDRESSES
BORDER SECURITY, CHAIN
MIGRATION AND THE VISA
LOTTERY.
IT DOES NOT INCLUDE A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP FOR
DREAMERS.
>> WE TOOK A WHIP CHECK.
THE WHIP CHECK WAS POSITIVE
AND WE'RE NOW WORKING ON THE
PEOPLE WHO WHIPPED BACK THAT
THEY WERE UNDECIDED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT AND WE'RE
PREPARED IT MAKE MORE TWEAKS
TO THE BILL IF NECESSARY.
>> NOW THAT SENATORS HAVE
RETURNED HOME FROM RECESS
WITHOUT A FIX, CANNOT
BELIEVE HOW BADLY DACA
RECIPIENTS HAVE BEEN TREATED
BY THE DEMOCRATS.
TOTALLY ABANDONED.
REPUBLICANS ARE STILL
WORKING HARD.
THAT TWEET GOT A RESPONSE
FROM THE DEMOCRATIC WHIP
SENATOR DICK DURBIN WHO SAYS
THIS IN PART, QUOTE.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
YOU KILLED DACA AND NOW
REJECTED SIX BIPARTISAN
DEALS TO PROTECT DREAMERS.
IDENTIFIABLE FIGHTING FOR
DREAMERS FOR 17 YEARS AND
WILL NEVER ABANDON THEM.
AND ACROSS THE CAPITAL IN
THE HOUSE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN CONGRESSMAN IS
NOW WARNING NOW BECAUSE
TRUMP SABOTAGED THE PROCESS
OF THE BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION, WE'LL CONTINUE
TO SEE THIS CRISIS WORSEN AS
DREAMERS CONTINUE TO LOSE
THEIR JOBS AND OTHERS ARE
DETAINED AND DEPORTED.
IT DOES APPEAR THE MARCH 5TH
DEADLINE PRESIDENT TRUMP
GAVE CONGRESS TO FIX DACA
MAY BE MOVING BACK WHILE THE
ADMINISTRATION FIGHTS WITH
FEDERAL JUDGES WHO SAY THE
PRESIDENT CAN'T CANCEL THE
PROGRAM.
AND SOME LAWMAKERS THINK
THEIR COLLEAGUES WELCOME THE
DELAY.
>> THE BOTTOM LINE IS, THIS
ALSO TELL ME THAT MAYBE
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE BEHIND
THE SCENES, THEY DON'T WANT
TO SOLVE IT DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS.
THEY WANT TO KEEP IT ALIVE
AS A CAMPAIGN ISSUE.
>> SO-CALLED SWEET SPOT ON
IMMIGRATION ACCORDING TO
REPUBLICAN SENATOR JOHN
THUNE COULD BE A STRIPPED
DOWN DEAL THAT JUST
ADDRESSES THE TWO BIG TICKET
ITEMS, DACA AND BORDER
SECURITY.
BUT THERE IS NO DEAL LIKE